hello everyone and welcome back to some
daily rapid action unleashes yesterday
we won a very nice game with the wi
pieces in the Evans Gambit so let's see
what we get today uh as usual we're
going to try and play some uh some good
moves uh try to explain our thought
process and uh hope uh hope we don't uh
do any uh great
mistakes so our opponent opens with C4
and we're going to counter it with
C5 uh I still don't have like a
repertoire against the English uh we're
playing against I want to I want to
sleep from Canada and he goes for G3 and
okay we're gonna we're going to mimic
him I think get our dark Square Bishop
as
well and go for some sort of a standard
setup uh and it all depends whether he
will go like maybe E4 or D4 maybe E3 and
D4 or maybe maybe D3 and D4 uh depending
on how he sets up his Pawn structure in
the center we're going to also set up
our Pawn structure accordingly so for
the moment we're just going to copy
him
uh and we'll see what it does okay so he
goes with the Knight we can also do that
but we can also just Advance this
Knight yeah we're going to
Castle and he's still reluctant to show
us what he what he's planning to do with
the central uh Pawn structure so we'll
we'll just
wait he's very very secretive about
it will it be like a D4 like Pro
probably it will be a D3 E4 if he's if
he's looking for some sort of a closed
setup but no he wants to play B4 yeah
still not showing me what his plans
are uh but okay he can play B4 not right
way of course he has to prepare it so
we're going to play Bishop to F5 just to
ask him what his plans are with the Rook
if he will put the pawn on
D3 uh yeah and
uh and um H do we want to play A5 here
is it something that we want to commit
to does seem like uh does seem like a
lot to commit
to
H yeah I don't know about
A5 I don't know about
A5
how do we how do we proceed
here let's go let's go Knight
here sort of sort of stop B4 because the
Knight here is inde
defended and then we'll
decide and our Knight isn't all that
impressive here okay so he plays this
first we're going to we're going to
attack the Knight here he plays H3 we
can even trade and get our Knights to E5
and D4 so that uh that makes
sense uh yeah okay so first we're going
to put a knight
here he goes back and now although
Knight E5 is a great Square for the
Knight he will just attack it with F4 so
it's not uh not the best
perhaps uh but yeah we can we can do
it yeah we can put the Knight here and
then shift this Knight back to C
six yeah okay and now he'll play he'll
play
B4 no he he he's uh uh improving the
position of his King
first all right let's let's figure this
out what's the best way to go about
this can't decide do I mind
B4
let's go H5 in the future we might have
some H4 action if needed if not it's uh
it's a pretty good
setup okay so he go he moves the V we're
going to play Rook to
B8 yeah okay so he wants to trade on
D4 and we might even consider B5
ourselves now yeah B5
ourselves
[Music]
um yeah let's do it yeah spent quite a
lot of time uh approaching this but uh
yeah it's not easy playing against these
setups where white goes for the early
fetto of the light Square bishop and
just does nothing uh very hard to find a
sort of a game plan that that you can
use but uh yeah okay he's playing it
slow so we have uh we have a lot of
options here
so B5 uh B4 also not out of the question
B4 is always a move with
white and now we are sort of threatening
to open up the B file a little bit sort
of weaken the center so he has
to find a way to react to this I don't
imagine him playing
B3 although he
might and uh yeah if we if we are happy
with our setup here it's time to bring
the queen and the Rooks into the game so
uh I I do want to play uh on the on the
queen side I do have my pawns sort of
facing this way and the bishop is here
and if I can get my queen let's say to
A5 maybe get the other Rook active as
well uh should be okay if he doesn't
have any sort of kingside action with
something like F5 F5 could be could be
annoying uh but for the moment I don't
think it's uh it's that impressive like
he could play I could even maybe capture
but yeah probably not capturing should
be the way to
go yeah he will trade once
first and now uh yeah now I'm thinking I
even capture here yeah I'm thinking I
even capture here this does sort of
expose my my
knight uh but
not not by a lot
yeah he will take this first and now the
question is do I do I move the Knight do
I capture on B5 or do I take the
bishop so I'm thinking uh I'm thinking
Rook captures on B5 is the
move
yeah yeah okay so he goes for this and
now we just uh we just play Pawn to
E6 sort of have everything uh under
control here we do have very nice
control over F5 if he advances the pawn
to E5 we can advance our Pawn to
D5 yeah I was also considering this move
but now we can just play Queen to
B6 yeah B4 of
course nothing wrong with
B4 what's the best way to approach this
yeah okay let's
uh
let's just double up
here or rather triple up here triple up
here and we're preparing some A5 action
so probably he moves the queen
now yeah it's a really really funny
position yeah I do have a doubled
doubled D Pawn but uh it's uh nicely
defended so I don't mind that okay so he
shifts the attention to the C6 Knight as
he
should uh but still doesn't look like uh
doesn't look like it's something to
worry about yeah probably like A4 he
wants to
capture um which is which is
[Music]
fine yeah we can also just play this
yeah it's not a
problem we're going to capture back with
the Knight and then he does have the
past a pawn although it's not uh it's
not not that impressive
really okay we we should play a little
bit faster but he's also spending a lot
of time here and he does have a
wonderful Bishop pair here uh but uh
once I once I figure out how to properly
set up my knight I think we're going to
be okay as we don't have that many
weaknesses we have a nice Bishop once
the Knight is figured out we have the
the triple battery here on the B file
yeah it's
uh it's a nice uh nice position also D5
Pawn is nicely defended I like that now
it's a merely a matter of what to do
with the Knight and I I can also
infiltrate already but then I'll maybe
allow him to infiltrate
although yeah I don't
know I guess we still wait with that
yeah maybe something like this and if
plays Rook B1 I just uh Fork his Rooks
we trade once here and we can sort of go
into the end game uh although again not
sure if I'm if I'm up for
that yeah some okay so he goes
uh he goes in with the
Rook not bad not
bad
um
yeah once he plays this he's going to
lock my Bishop out of the defense of the
pawn so we also have to worry about that
a little
bit we also have to worry about that a
little bit so
h
yeah let's go
here sort of If he if he does this I
want to have my Pawn defended and then
we'll figure out how to how to keep it
defended and if he doesn't do all that
much I might even have some Knight to C5
action with an attack on the queen and
on the pawn
here but still not really sure how to
follow up on
that yeah okay so he goes for this as
we've uh as we've
expected uh but now we can just
uh we can just make our position more
solid
here yeah since he goes after that we'll
just play E5
here really wanted this Pawn to be
nicely defended
like he might play F5 here but I don't
think that's an issue now uh the Rooks
moved
away yeah okay he could double up
here
definitely uh but then uh the the
position in the center is already
figured out uh shouldn't be shouldn't be
much of a much of an
issue
yeah okay let's go for it let's go for
it he wants to do it let's do
it and with his Bishops locked in like
this uh I will have I will have some
time to figure out how to how to go
about with the pawn here yeah let's
trade
here and we can just trade
everything now we're going to take with
the
Rook
and the nice thing is is that if he
captures no of course he wants to get
his
uh he wants to get his pieces into the
game
um yeah we should also get our King into
the game
definitely okay let's let's save our
Pawn from any any troubles that he
might run into and now we're going to
go shift the Knight
here maybe I could have done it quicker
but he always has Bishop to F1 this Pawn
will be nicely defended and he does have
the Bishop pair uh but
luckily y okay
F5 uh
[Music]
F5 yeah let's go
here if he trades no he's not going to
trade of
course let's go after that pawn
now okay so he wants to trade everything
here which is
fine let's go
here just improve our position as much
as
possible okay let's go
here we might even have a have a little
check here in store for
him doesn't do a
lot but we can sort of go after the
Pawn yeah one Pawn is
enough
maybe yeah okay so he will go after our
Pawn here but uh it will be defended so
it's not an
issue yeah okay this is maybe not the
best move I I thought I had to defend it
with the Knight so yeah that's problem
he of course wants to fix my my pawns on
uh on the light
squares uh we're going to go
here so he can attack them with my
Bishop yeah okay so he goes
here
H what about this
Pawn what about this
Pawn
yeah okay so he goes after the knight uh
he wants this
Square uh okay so now it's a race now
it's a race we're going to take
here so to defend our Pawn he's going to
attack our Knight now he just goes to
defend but now okay we have check and we
just push the pawn and we win so it was
a it was a good game
but uh somehow the Knight here prevailed
but it was a I mean okay now it's it's
an open position but it was a fairly
closed one okay so now let's just not
blunder any checks I don't think he has
any like uh he can play this okay I
don't buy that for a
second uh not going to work yeah okay so
he wants this check uh which is
something that we have to
prevent yeah that's not a bad move not a
bad move at
all
uh but okay I mean I don't think we have
a a way of stopping that if I go here
he'll just go here so I have to do it oh
no it comes with check wow yeah he he
tricked me into into believing that he
has a check and he could give up his
Bishop wow so silly so silly of me uh
but yeah I think it was uh perhaps not
the greatest one but uh yeah let's let's
see what we could have done better so C4
like I said I don't have some sort of a
system against the English I just played
like I would against um maybe the hyper
accelerated Dragon so that I I use that
um pieces for my setup and uh then it
really all depends on what he does with
the E Pawn and the D Pawn uh where I
will be able to to fight for the center
or we're going to you know go around
like we did in this game so I play
Knight F6 uh yeah he he really waited
with those pawns he played Rook
B1 yeah sort of D5 is the way to go and
while I know this from from like uh
principal you know General chess
knowledge um I don't know I figured that
since he's playing this whole setup with
with pressure on on my B file uh I
thought maybe yeah D6 was the way to go
I play Bishop to F5 he played D3 I
played Knight D7 he played E5 okay
Bishop G4 here we traded once and I
played Knight to D4 so now sort of a z00
position I played Knight E5 sort maybe
something better here yeah Knight E5
it's even the most common move played
here F4 I played Knight to C6 uh he
played King H2 I played H5 yeah sort of
A5 yeah the move that I was uh uh so so
much avoiding to play uh obviously is
the way to go I played H5 and he still
waited with B4 now I play Rook B1 again
B4 should be played yeah but it's like
the entire game I was uh reluctant to
stop B4 and he was reluctant to play
when it was always the best move but
yeah sometimes uh yeah sometimes it
happens so I played B5 again B4 here the
move that we discussed captures captures
yeah sort of capturing with the bishop
is the way to go but I thought this
would be a bit more impressive he played
uh captures I played Rook captures and
he played Bishop back here okay I played
Pawn to E6 he played Queen to A4 Queen
to B6 uh and finally B4 and as you can
see still an equal position z0
I tripled up here he played Rook C1 I
played A5 yeah those are all very nice
moves uh and now after Rook C2 Knight B3
uh yeah I did consider this move I did
consider this move but I thought nah I
always play something like that and then
it just turns into a long-term weakness
uh yeah E5 sort of Knight to C5 right
away a little bit better but I thought
uh trading everything would uh would
serve my purpose uh and now okay Knight
C5 blunders the game for some reason I I
I have to capture here Knight C5 why
does it blunder the game
oh yeah that's uh that's a bit
embarrassing why did we both miss
that yeah if if he captures here he he
just takes a full Rook
wow he has to take with the queen W
that's super
impressive and then uh he's just up a
full Rook yeah wow that's uh that's
really sad he went for Rook actress and
now yeah he he trusted me that this was
this was best and now it's again z0 play
King f8 and now it's uh it's an end game
that I'm pretty sure we played pretty
much uh to a draw uh but then at some
point I was able to to grab the full
point yeah okay
G4 captures captures I went for the pawn
here uh not the best sort of G5
here H sort of just just trap my bishop
and then if I go here like Pawn to F6 no
Bishop to F3
okay oh yeah I'm sort of running out of
moves here uh but yeah he played Bishop
to F3 and now Bishop to H6 check uh
allows this yeah but uh I played this
first and it's a draw it's better to
play King to C2 yeah it's a it's it's a
matter of living living leaving him out
of moves before he leaves me out of
moves but I was afraid that here I might
just give a a super strong pass Pawn but
obviously C4 is faster yeah captur
send uh Bishop here yeah we'll we'll get
the job done yeah there there there you
have it a nice misplay a couple of
misplays already uh yeah here just
captures and now okay now it's winning
yeah Knight Here pawn goes here and now
we just Advance the
pawn
uh sorry I went into went into a wrong
line here I defended the pawn when in
fact yeah Knight A6 I said that I did
say that yeah it was a bit silly to
overprotect the C the the D6 Pawn uh but
I I I completely forgot that the bishop
was also defending it uh we have G6 okay
King here still still a
draw uh and now after yeah he attacked
my knight now it's winning for me Knight
to C5 captures captures and now the pass
Pawn will decide the game as it should
have in the previous lines
yeah did I mess up anything else yeah I
plays this D2 yeah and he even tricked
me here in at the end I completely
forgot that this comes with check
because he played this so quickly I
thought yeah okay he nice find uh but
yeah after this is just a forc Checkmate
uh so yeah very interesting stuff and um
as usual uh you know I make these uh
videos where I play sort of to give you
an example of uh of the thought process
that goes on and how I how I decide deci
side on which move I play sometimes I
will blunder terribly like in this game
like I I left the whole Rook hanging
here I was uh pretty bad maneuver even
though up until this point everything
was perfectly fine uh but yeah what's
the idea like yeah captures captures and
Bishop to H6 that's the that's the way
to defend yeah that's the way to do it
uh but here I I just play not to C5 yeah
and he could have just uh grabbed a full
Rook but sometimes you know I trust my
opponent some times my opponents trust
me and you know uh one one day you teach
your opponent a lesson the next day he
he he gives you one uh but yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it uh uh
nicely done by me what are you going to
do you know thank you for I want to uh
sleep for for contributing by playing
this game as usual you can check to my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your
day